Back to the Future with the seal of
approval from the president Leo varadka
resumed the office of teacher Irish
Prime Minister
at a special setting of parliament he'd
accepted the nomination to replace
Michal Martin who's rotated out under
the Dale underpinning Coalition I want
to take this opportunity to commend Neil
Martin on the leadership that he showed
as teacher
for putting the country before politics
and for providing reassurance and hope
during difficult times as t-shirt my
mission will be to build on the
achievement of a hundred years ago
and to work on what needs to be done for
this generation and the next
providing hope and housing economic
economic opportunities and a fair start
for all
Leo varadker a medical doctor made
history five years ago becoming
Ireland's youngest prime minister and
its first gay one the son of an Indian
doctor and Irish nurse he and his
British counterpart Rishi sunak have
much in common they do have similar
backgrounds and you know it is you know
Leo ragger is the first gay teacher that
we've ever had the first minority
t-shirt that we've ever had we know
Richardson first minority prime minister
so they do have that in common so I do
think this is a fresh start I think
Rishi sunak has signaled already that he
is Keen to get a date on brexit that he
is trying to sort this out and I think
if they both men will go under this with
that on their mind that they want to get
this ordered
but sorting it won't be easy when
unionists blame layover radcar more than
Boris Johnson for the Northern Ireland
protocol
loyalists are markingly over radkor's
return as t-shirt by threatening
violence and that's because he warned
the EU that a hard border on this island
could result in Ira violence in other
words they hold him personally
responsible for the brexit Border in the
Irish sea
Billy Hutchinson a former loyalist
prisoner turned politician wants the
teacher to address the anger I think
usually whenever anybody has a dislike
for anybody anger comes first and others
what happened you know you can have you
can have an argument with their
neighbors but you have to resolve it and
this is exactly what this is like only
it's on a bigger scale so from that
point of view I think he needs if he
really wants Ireland the Republic of
Ireland to work then he needs to make
sure that he has friendly neighbors and
people who understand what he's trying
to do
he's not as popular as he once was
having become embroiled in the
controversial leaking of a GP contract
to a friend Leo varadker will be hoping
he has at least two years to turn the
polling figures around before the next
general election David Blevins Sky News